vendredi 4 novembre 2022 le mercure
indique 20 degrés Celsius au thermomètre
un vendredi d'été sur fond de paysage
d'automne à Montréal aux quatre coins de
la planète la chaleur et la sécheresse
ont marqué la dernière année selon
l'Organisation météorologique mondiale
2015 à 2022 sont les années les plus
chaudes depuis que l'on mesure des
données du climat avec des instruments
pour 2022 la température moyenne a été
supérieure de 1,15 degrés Celsius a
l'air pré-industriel au 19e siècle ben
ça montre vraiment qu'il faut bouger
rapidement si on veut contrecarrer cette
tendance là
dans un rapport publié la veille du Jour
de la Terre l'agence spécialisée de
l'ONU fait état du climat avec
différents indicateurs climatiques
incluant la fonte des glaciers qui a
aussi fracassé des records l'épaisseur
moyenne des glaciers a diminué de 1,3 m
la perte la plus significative depuis 10
ans phénomène de fonte qui s'observe
aussi pour les glaciers Canadiens le
stress hydrique va augmenter en
contrefort des Rocheuses dans les
Prairies canadiennes directement en
réponse à la perte des surfaces de glace
les changements climatiques ont des
impacts environnementaux mais aussi
socio-économique comme le souligne le
rapport de l'OM on peut penser au vague
de chaleur ou encore les plus Records
qui entraînent une baisse de rendement
agricole et crée de l'insécurité
alimentaire surtout en Asie et en
Afrique
le secrétaire général de l'OM estime que
ces tendances météorologiques pourraient
se poursuivre jusque dans les années
2060 car à son avis annuler les effets
négatifs des gaz à effet de serre
prendra quelques décennies malgré les
actions que l'on pose aujourd'hui pour
réduire les changements climatiques ici
Carla Oliveira Radio-Canada Montréal